[Music]
memory is everything
without it we are blind
[Music]
without it we lead the plate of our
world to chance
i'm sorry to disturb you thomas but i've
just received troubling news tell me
what is it it's grindelwald
our time is closed my brothers and
sisters our wall with the knuckles the
kings
today
the world as we know it is coming undone
if we're to defeat him
you'll have to trust me mr kowalski we
need you said i wanted out on that one
out
you do know i'm a witch right
dumbledore said i give you something
jacob
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous visit in this
century
who wouldn't like our chances
[Music]
oh
no one can know everything
not even you
[Music]
what are you doing is madness
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
dangerous times
favor dangerous men
if by tea time all of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
mr kowalski my pleasure
do you really intend to turn your back
on your kind
of said we could reshape the world even
if we make mistakes
we can try to make things right
[Music]
we're gonna need some help
[Music]
that's nothing you can do to stop me
[Music]
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
i trust you're enjoying your wand mr
kowalski
can i keep this
[Music]
[Music]
you